[Música]
nós vamos falar aqui do profissional do
futuro e mais especificamente da
formação do profissional do futuro uma
vez que eu sou convidado a falar aqui a
partir da experiência na é que eu tenho
na educação é formar o profissional do
futuro hoje requer muito mais do que em
qualquer tempo do passado a atividade da
educação durante milhares de anos se
formava as pessoas praticamente sem
educação
melhor dizendo sem qualquer tipo de
educação formal
isso não é um demérito eu estava hoje
lembrando uma coisa que a professora
cléia bose uma das grandes conhecedores
no brasil tanto da questão da memória
quanto à questão do mundo caipira uma
coisa que eu criei a bossa costumava
dizer
o caipira não é nada tosco caipira
contrário àquele que sabia ao essencial
então você tem informações sem nenhuma
educação formal mas que têm um
conhecimento do essencial que é fabuloso
e provavelmente esse conhecimento que o
caipira tem ou tinha o essencial era um
conhecimento que dominava tanto o saber
o conhecimento formalizado
quanta sabedoria uma experiência humana
valores éticos capacidade de lidar com
as pessoas de relacionar se com elas o
que domina tanto a psicologia quanto à
ética hoje em dia então não se trata da
gente dizer a educação a varre o mundo
de ignorância não é bem isso a educação
um tipo de informação que vai se
desenvolvendo nos últimos séculos que é
extremamente importante como é que para
o profissional do futuro vai ser
importante e cada vez mais importante
assim como hoje para a produção
econômica e qualquer tipo de produção
mesmo não monetizáveis a ciência
tecnologia pesquisa de qualidade vão se
tornando cada vez mais decisivo se podia
fazer um produto algumas décadas atrás
com baixo teor de inteligência hoje cada
produto tem muita inteligência
provavelmente cada um de vocês tem no
corpo
alguma coisa que reflete descobertas
científicas dos últimos dois anos
todo mundo tem isso pode estar num
elemento decorativo pode estar na roupa
pode estar na caneta
não estou nem falando do celular
smartphone falando em coisas muito mais
tradicionais elas têm tecnologia têm
ciência recente
por isso mesmo o profissional do futuro
precisará ter uma formação muito
qualificada em termos de educação
é claro que a educação educação e
tecnológica mente vem do latim velho do
que ele que está parecem conduzir
deduzir induzir reduzir o que quer dizer
levar conduzir digamos e o prefixo ex
que é sair de dentro para fora e de como
movimento de dentro pra fora
então educar é conduzir de dentro para
fora e levar do ambiente fechado para um
ambiente aberto dentro fechado para o
fora que o mundo todo educar é abrir
para o mundo então o trabalho de
educação e é um trabalho fundamental tl
que faz cada um de nós aí do mundo
pequeno que em outras culturas podia ser
um mundo maravilhoso o mundo alto
referido auto suficiente de uma tribo de
um grupo étnico de uma cultura forte
internamente que não se não lida com as
outras e que vai se tornando cada vez
mais impossível insustentável e até
deficiente no mundo atual
então à medida que nós abrimos as
pessoas para o mundo nós damos outras
oportunidades a elas
isso cada vez mais vai ser exigido no
mundo do trabalho que as pessoas tenham
capacitações diferentes das anteriores
muita gente fala em ter habilidades
novas e não gosta desse tempo a
habilidade uma tradição mal feita do
inglês ability habilidade em português é
uma coisa que você nasce geralmente é
isso então há pessoas aqui têm muita
habilidade manual
há pessoas que não têm nenhuma entre as
quais eu me incluo a outras habilidades
que as pessoas podem ter para tal coisa
que outros não têm
habilite em inglês é o que é adquirido
que é formado que é feito então ability
pode ser uma competência reforma
competências pode ser uma capacidade
você capacita pessoas então a educação
tem um aspecto muito importante que ela
vai no plano mais tecnológico diria ela
vai fazer que as pessoas
se se tem cada vez mais competências
isso não é o mais difícil nem o mais
importante da educação mas é crucial é
decisivo
significa por exemplo praticamente todo
pesquisar profissional do futuro terá
que dominar a computação e o acesso à
rede mundial a internet isso é
praticamente básico
qual o nível de formação disso é variado
mas quer dizer praticamente a questão do
acesso à informação ea formação que o
computador à internet todo produzido é
uma coisa essencial e todo o curso de
graduação me parece deveria incluir uma
certa o brinca de como você utiliza
melhor a internet e mesmo os programas
disponíveis de computador para fazer
melhor a sua coisa é um passo básico
tada no nível tecnológico no nível
também formal conhecer uma língua
estrangeira importante e decisivo
geralmente em inglês
podemos também colocar outras formas de
conhecer isso são importantes
algo que é fundamental na formação seja
do do graduando seja do mestrado
profissional em especial é a pessoa
saber onde vai poder que encontrar
matéria para o que ela está fazendo
ninguém vai parar ninguém vai poder
parar num certo momento o seu acesso ao
conhecimento
a ideia que havia antigamente que isso
vocês formava na faculdade e nunca mais
pesava lá muito
já li muita coisa assim sai da faculdade
do livro nunca mais pisar aqui tem meu
canudo
acabou acabou você vai ter o tempo todo
que se reeducar não necessariamente na
faculdade não necessariamente naquela
mas vai ter que se entrar de novo em
contato com o conhecimento tem uma coisa
importante da graduação o mestrado
profissional porque não dizer no ensino
médio que é onde termina a escolaridade
obrigatória no brasil 14 anos
os 4 17 aos 17 e 18 anos e se forma no
ensino médio e terminou a escolaridade
obrigatória no brasil ea maior parte não
vai passar disso
pois bem nessa você tem também que saber
como você vai encontrar mais como você
vai pesquisar mais
como você vai adquirir conhecimento para
resolver
mas isso tudo são competências
capacitações que o dia básicas quase
formais mas as competências de conteúdo
que são as principais competências de
conteúdo
antes de mais nada é ela deve ser
baseada em algo que é muito importante
que aparece no livro sapiens daquele
escritor israelense yuval harare sei
quem de vocês leão mas parece que vários
que é um livro muito interessante pra
pensar que essa mudança que o mundo está
vivendo esse futuro de um salto
qualitativo gigantesco para nós e que
uns mais outros menos onde viver
de agora em diante pois bem nos sap ele
diz a nossa sociedade é a sociedade que
mais produziu conhecimento mas teve
acesso ao conhecimento porque porque a
sociedade que mais têm a noção de quanto
desconhece justamente porque sabemos que
somos ignorantes sociedade que mais
conhece ele compara a 200 300 anos atrás
quanto às sociedades não houve que não
tinham a noção da própria ignorância uma
pessoa ignorante uma das características
dela é que ela não sabe que é ignorante
já pensa que ela sabe um monte de coisas
por isso não é curiosa ela não procura
eta abrir se para o mundo perceber
outras coisas isso foi possível
dizem que no século 18 viveu o último
homem a conhecer tudo
cartazes qishan um pensador que age em
todas as áreas do conhecimento
chega uma hora que ninguém é capaz de
dominar física química matemática a
filosofia e história artes não dá porque
tudo explodiu tanto que é impossível
alguém conhecer tudo e mais do que isso
nós começamos a ficar atentos à nossas
falhas
o que rompe com o pensamento de matriz
religiosa que dizia deus revelou
sabemos tudo o que não está aí não é
importante a frase atribuída ao sultão
que mandou queimar a biblioteca de
alexandria vejam o que ele mandou fazer
e ele diz seus livros estão aí dizem o
mesmo que o corão são inúteis se dizem
outras coisas que ocorreram são
perigosos podem todos os reformados ou
se é uma forma muito clara e dizer eu
sei tudo
então não preciso de mais nada é quando
nós cobrimos como espécie que saber um
pouco que isso muda
olhem hoje o perfil por exemplo que são
favoráveis e contrários à educação no
brasil você tem dois grandes grupos de
campanha contra a educação
um grupos é o que falar em ideologia de
gênero outro fala em escolas sem
partido-ro tive um certo contato com
eles quando dirigiu o ministério da
educação 2015
esses grupos têm em comum medo
extraordinário do poder que a educação
tem de abrir a cabeça das pessoas não
querem isso
uma faixa essa escola é ensino educação
com os pais
quer dizer não queremos que nossos
filhos se abram para o mundo
queremos que nossos filhos fiquem dentro
do espaço o que eles estão se ele se
abre para o mundo
ele escapa do nosso controle a primeira
versão do projeto de lei da escola sem
partido dizia que não se poderia ensinar
na escola nada contra diga a religião da
da criança então se a criança tem uma
religião criacionista você não poderia
ensinar física para poder ensinar
nenhuma ciência porque ou então teve que
ensinar ao mesmo tempo que a ciência o
mito da criação do mundo em sete dias
e notem a maioria esmagadora dos
cientistas hoje no mundo são de formação
e muitas vezes de fé cristã judaica
alguma fé religiosa e no entanto nenhum
deles aceita a narrativa do começo do
gênesis como base científica todos
entendem isso como metáfora sobre tudo
velho testamento válido pela grande
maioria dos cristãos como metafórico não
como a pé da letra
vocês vejam que bloquearia tudo isso em
termos de conhecimento e aí o hara e
fala da desse princípio que você
apresentasse consumo da sua própria
ignorância para conhecer coisa nova e um
gatuno um grande filósofo filósofo que é
praticamente o divisor de águas na área
que o estudo que eu estudei que sócrates
que sócrates pregar proclamavam pegava
nada ele proclamava proclamava só sei
que nada sei
ou seja uma ignorância sofisticada
a ignorância de quem não sabe uma coisa
noreci quem sabe que não sabe e sabendo
que não sabe vai procurar alguma coisa
nova porque é um salto qualitativo uma
qualidade gigantesca de avanço na na
vida humana
então isso é um ponto crucial do
profissional do futuro
nós temos que educar as pessoas para
saberem porque elas vão ter
e nesse sentido que eu discordo de um
discurso muito comum no na nossa
sociedade e que presidiu por exemplo a
reforma do ensino médio recentemente
feita pelo governo que hoje está aí que
é um reforço das matérias científicas
física química biologia e da matemática
em prejuízo das matérias humanas
filosofia sociologia história por
exemplo porque eu discordo porque estou
convencido de que para a formação da
pessoa do futuro uma boa formação as
matérias humanas é essencial é preciso
que você saiba certas coisas básicas têm
18 anos os jovens que estão se formando
no ensino médio na idade certa época em
que eles podem assinar contratos
antigamente os 21 se podia assinar
contratos e tinha uma maioria 18 e uma
prioridade e uma maioridade plena aos 21
todo tudo hoje está o 18
isso quer dizer que esses jovens podem
casar podem comprar casa podem firmar
empréstimos podem assumir compromissos
de causa em questão o cenário de danos
para eles a vida ao longo de algum dia
no ensino médio eles aprenderam sobre
isso algum dia eles foi ensinado que é
contrato o que são as consequências de
um contrato para não falar do que é um
casamento não foi
as pessoas sabem muito pouco sobre isso
é isso a minha proposta tanto que o
prego alguns anos é o seguinte vamos
ensinar em filosofia vamos ensinar a
ética um ano de ética um ano e teoria
política para as pessoas saberem que a
direita esquerda parlamentares um
presidencialismo a polícia o socialismo
liberalismo sem doutrinar ninguém
ensinar
vamos ensinar um ano de lógica para as
pessoas aprenderem fala coisa com coisa
que é uma coisa minha
com deficiência um dos grandes problemas
do brasil em sociologia vamos ensinar a
economia continuar como funciona o
capitalismo é o modo de produção
dominante hoje no mundo todo e vamos
também ensinar como são as os limites
possam capitalismo por movimentos
sociais movimentos trabalhistas
movimentos ambientais que evitaram que
essa técnica estupenda do capitalismo
envenenar se o mundo capitalista o
fabuloso para produzir riqueza e
eticamente é pelo menos neutro
se você não tiver limitações de fora não
funciona então temos que ensinar o
começo do ensino médio como se faz a
riqueza e na sequência porque não como
se fabrica a pobreza que a grande
matéria da sociologia
quem vai ler um jornal já o caderno
geralmente segundo o jornal sociedade
cidade cotidiano são paulo sete cidades
como é que se chame o segundo caderno
vai tratar dos temas nacional dia
pobreza desigualdade e serviços públicos
deficientes sem conhecer a sociologia
você corre o risco de ver tudo isso que
pensar uma pessoa pobre porque ela
simplesmente vagabunda transformar a
pobreza em caso de polícia que também é
uma tradição inclusive temos tivemos um
governador do estado washington luís
de quem é a famosa frase questão social
é um caso de polícia
então ou você forma uma pessoa pra
entender de outro jeito
ou você não vai ter espaço para elas
enfrentar em um mundo e com isso nós
chegamos a necessidade temos
profissionais que sejam capazes de
enfrentar o mundo
o problema é que nós estamos tendo hoje
no brasil é que a pretexto de reduzir
porque alguns acham ser uma visão muito
politizada nas matérias de humanas que
na verdade existe muito pouco no ensino
médio - ainda no fundamental a pretexto
disso está se por vezes destruindo a
capacidade dos nossos profissionais de
se internacionalizarem de dialogarem com
os possíveis concorrentes fora vejam
décadas atrás
fatores de vantagem do brasil
economicamente falando era
mas muito espaço para poluir além de
embaixadores brasileiros encontros
mundiais de preocupados com o flagelo da
poluição que diziam o brasil acolhe de
bom com braços abertos
a fumaça a poluição tudo que enriqueceu
os países de vocês que nós queremos
agora também enriquecer dizendo que o
combate à poluição era de gente que já
enrico ou pela poluição e que depois
está querendo se livrar disso em vez de
pensarem vamos aproveitar a experiência
dos outros para enriquecer sem poluir
fizeram esses desastres que nós hoje
pagamos então é essa visão que o nós
temos sobretudo fora de uma economia
mais sustentável de uma economia que não
se divorcia da sociedade de uma de um
mundo que seja mais aberto com o mundo
porém que não tenha miséria sociedades
recusam a miséria é um traço distintivo
dos países avançados do mundo hoje e que
ainda o flagelo brasileiro piorado ainda
depois do afastamento da presidente
dilma rousseff
esta diferença acho que é um dos pontos
cruciais para se formar um bom
profissional e um bom profissional se o
profissional não souber lidar com os
custos sociais ambientais e tudo está
fazendo
se não souber atender ao mesmo tempo a
produção mais elevada e evitar se a
produção gere efeitos colaterais
péssimos
nós temos um grande exemplo as marginais
dos rios mas ocupamos o que era dos rios
tietê e pinheiros que temos enchentes e
teremos sempre a não ser que a gente
fala demolir quilômetros kms quadrados e
condomínios ricos que estão ali o que é
impossível então esse negócio antecipará
coisa errada que ter uma cabeça que
pensa em termos globais e não apenas
temos fechado sendo os grandes combates
que temos hoje para concluir o dia
nossa diferença hoje é nós queremos uma
cabeça fechada ou queremos uma cabeça
aberta
se queremos uma cabeça aberta nós temos
que ter uma cabeça cheia de curiosidade
com a cabeça que possa colocar a
pergunta sobre o que está pela frente e
o que vai na cabeça capaz de colocar a
si própria em chat em questão e nós
temos que pensar de maneira plena
não podemos pensar só
casinha aumenta o pib diminuiu pipe
aumenta a produção de mel produção que o
mundo todo está envolvido em cada coisa
10 que o mundo todo se joga a cada
instante aqui no local
obrigado e bons pensamentos para vocês
todos
[Aplausos]